les années 60 sont toujours à la mode en
france le spectacle âge tendre et têtes
de bois qui fait revivre les grands
tubes de cette période rencontre un
succès assez inattendu michèle torr jean
jacques debout encore franck à la mosson
remonter ensemble sur scène pour une
tournée triomphale dans toute la france
abdelah mostefa emmanuel maurel voir la
tournée des idoles c'est comme glisser
une quarantaine d'euros free du billet
dans un doute boss géants maestro
oh
ce qui me plaît
je m'appelle des mes 20 ans l'aînée avec
ses chansons la somalie
autres ayants droit d'y aller
de ce sang donne le premier jour
les gens croyaient qu'on était des
saisies dans les douze morts
et puis après ça s'est très bien passé
parce que le premier jour passé le
deuxième jour troisième jour on a vu que
c'était formidable pour moi la vie va
commencer
sur le même plateau une douzaine de
vedette de la variété des années 60 70
sans la crainte du trou de mémoire
on ajouté
un brin kitsch sur le papier la recette
s'est avéré finalement payante c'est la
caravane c'est une troupe a fait une
très facile à huy au bout de 4 35 40
spectacles
on a vu venir à nous les médias alors
qu'au départ si on avait appelé ans nous
avions fait une tournée on risque est
tombé sur des gens qui auraient dit
horace et une tournée de has been
c'était une bien de tournée d'adieu qui
ne dit pas son nom
sur la place
jean de tournes le ciel le soleil
et la paix
les concerts jusqu'à fin 2007 dans tous
les zénith de france
les idoles profite à plein du papy boom